it's okay to have like a different
lifestyle and not not want to have a
traditional lifestyle but your Society
absolutely should promote traditional
Lifestyles there's nothing wrong with
with being like yo men and women should
get married and have kids because that's
how we continue our society and as much
as there's a lot of people out there
that that are are screaming about
um about the the over overpopulation
about and worries about climate change
and stuff if I understand correctly the
the fact that so many societies are
getting so old now like China and the us
is going to be a pretty old society and
you're having that happen throughout
Europe the birth rates are are so low
that we don't have to worry about
population or overpopulation there's
going to be a population collapse coming
I've been listening to a lot of videos
there are people that are talking about
by the end of the century the world
global population could be cut in half